you say this is a new kind of search
engine why would I use this instead of
google well it doesn't search the web so
there's there's a very significant
percentage of questions and queries that
are way better answer than a person
especially when you are asking the wrong
question you know only a only jelly can
tell you hey you asked the wrong
question like hey where's mission street
well where are you trying to go I'm
trying to go to so-and-so oh you don't
want mission there's a big thing going
on in Moscone and you should go on
Howard or whatever oh okay well what I
really want to know then is where is
Howard you know like but but a web
search engine will just keep telling you
all day long what you asked so let me
give you an example my producer candy
typed in who is Netanyahu she got an
answer in about 30 minutes but it was a
funny answer it's kind of a long damn
time but yeah he's the Prime Minister of
Israel a controversial fellow but to be
fair this is a really hard job it took a
little it took a little while though
yeah I mean what were what we're saying
is that's a feature not a bug because it
does web search likes to say like okay
we got you a hundred million results in
point 35 seconds which is great but then
you have to actually look through the
results and spend time and click on them
and look at them and get some semblance
of an answer so you actually spend
several minutes in your search well what
we're trying to do is say listen it
takes 13 seconds ask the question put
your phone down keep talking to the
person keep have lunch with your family
whatever will do the work for you and
then when the phone dings or whatever
here's your answer it's an answer on
demand and I we think the future of
searches you ask a question you just get
an answer so we're going to close that
gap from you know you got 30 minutes 10
or 15 minutes down to a second
eventually and we're starting with
people we're starting with just people
who know the answers and we'll ask and
you'll very often get that extra
information which is helpful you say
it's like search using Amazon echo
explain that to me well I'm just I'm I'm
envisioning a world and
which voice is the main UI so if you've
ever seen the movie her the guys like
not the falling in love with the AI but
even before that he's got a little thing
in his ear and he's just like email next
delete yeah okay read that one to me and
and and when you ask when you ask Alexa
question which I love I love Alexis
everybody should progress oh my god ever
wants to buy one that's so great but I
welcomed her into my home she's out that
she's at dinner with us like we're
talking about how far away is Mars but
if you ask your something like what's
that name of that tech company that all
those what's the name of that a club
that all those tech guys go to in San
Francisco she's just like boom boom or
like I don't know and a person will be
like oh that's called the battery and
it's a club in a restaurant and I've
been there before and it's mostly
self-congratulatory